CNN RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN NOW REPORT THAT THE
AMERICAN JOURNALIST, STEVEN
SOTLOFF, 31-YEAR-OLD FREELANCER,
HAS BEEN EXECUTED BY ISIS.
THEY'VE JUST RELEASED A
VIDEOTAPE.
ISIS, SHOWING THE EXECUTION OF
STEPHEN SOTLOFF.
ISIS RELEASED THE VIDEO.
ONCE AGAIN, A BRUTAL EXECUTION.
A BEHEADING OF THIS JOURNALIST,
THIS AMERICAN JOURNALIST.
KARL PENHAUL IS JOINING US FROM
LONDON RIGHT NOW.
WE KNOW THAT THEY'VE POSTED
STILL PHOTOS, KARL, ON TWITTER
AND ELSEWHERE, IS THAT RIGHT,
THIS IS COMING FROM ISIS?
>> WOLF, IN FACT, A VIDEO HAS
ALSO BEEN POSTED ONLINE.
WE'RE SHOWING YOU RIGHT NOW, THE
STILLS, AGAIN, THAT IS PART OF
OUR EDITORIAL POLICY.
NOT TO SHOW AND REFLECT THE ISIS
PROPAGANDA VIDEOS THAT ARE GOING
OUT AND ALSO TO TRY TO REMEMBER
THESE PEOPLE IN LIFE RATHER THAN
IN DEATH.
BUT, YES, THIS ISIS VIDEO, A
LITTLE OVER TWO MINUTES IN
LENGTH.
ONCE AGAINST, WE ARE SEEING A
MAN WITH AN APPARENT BRITISH
ACCENT DRESSED IN HEAD TO TOE IN
BLACK.
APART FROM SAND COLORED DESERT
COMBAT BOOTS.
HE HAS A KNIFE IN HIS LEFT HAND.
THE OPENING WORDS THERE FROM
STEVEN SOTLOFF SAYING THAT "YOU
KNOW WHO I AM BY NOW AND YOU
KNOW WHY I AM HERE."
THAT IS THE PRELUDE, REALLY, TO
WHAT THEN COMES, AND LATER ON IN
THIS VIDEO, WE SEE, ONCE AGAIN,
THAT APPARENTLY BRITISH ACCENTED
EXECUTIONER THEN POINTING HIS
KNIFE INTO THE CAMERA ONCE
AGAIN, AS HE DID WITH THAT
BRUTAL EXECUTION VIDEO OF JAMES
FOLEY, SAYING, "OBAMA, I AM
BACK," INDICATING THIS IS
POSSIBLY THE SAME MAN THAT TOOK
THAT ACTION AGAINST JAMES FOLEY,
AND THEN PROCEEDS TO PASS A
COMBAT KNIFE ACROSS STEVEN
FOLEY'S THROAT BEFORE THAT VIDEO
FADES TO BLACK.
ONCE IT DOES FADE TO BLACK, ONCE
AGAIN, WE SEE A GRUESOME PICTURE
AFTER THAT, A BLOOD SOAKED BODY,
DRESSED IN THE ORANGE UNIFORM,
SIMILAR TO THE UNIFORMS THE
GUANTANAMO PRISONERS WERE HELD
IN, AND WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
SEVERED HEAD ON TOP OF THAT
BODY.
THIS VIDEO, LIKE THE LAST VIDEO,
WE SEE ANOTHER HOSTAGE THERE.
APPARENTLY AN INDICATION THERE
HE MAY BE THE NEXT MAN.
WE'RE WORKING HARD TO IDENTIFY
HIM, GET SOME MORE DETAILS ABOUT
HIM IN THIS VIDEO.
THE EXECUTIONER OR APPARENT
EXECUTIONER, AS HE WAVES HIS
KNIFE, HE SAYS, OBAMA, BACK OFF
AND JUST LEAVE US ALONE.
AGAIN, BRUTAL PROPAGANDA VIDEO
ONCE AGAIN.
IT SEEMS THAT THE WORST HAS
HAPPENED WITH FELLOW